we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p here's
an interesting voicemail i received yes
david lewis hello this is Fred from
estero florida and i'm kind of the day
of your marijuana story to say that i
think there is a good reason why all
these drugs should be legalized because
it would change the heart of america
from thinking that people have problems
with those drugs are criminals instead
of addicts we should be taking care of
people not punishing them yeah the thing
is you could achieve some of that by
decriminalization so that's already in
the same way that we don't think of
people who speed as criminals right
those are civil offenses if you
decriminalize drugs and make them civil
offenses uh you also are are making it
so that people who use them are not
criminal so I'm interested in the idea
of focusing on drug use as a health
issue I agree with that but you don't
need full legalization to decriminalize
by its very definition the
decriminalization of all drugs would
achieve that an interesting voicemail
nonetheless on the bonus show today we
will talk about Kopi Luwak coffee I
actually have a story about this coffee
which I will tell on the bonus show we
will also meet Europe's oldest living
inhabitant and lastly a fisherman kept
the world's most valuable pearl under
his bed all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show there is one way to
sign up for membership and get access to
the bonus show and that's by going to
david pakman.com slash membership and if
you want a discount off of membership
use coupon code hey tree at 40 when you
check out